Let's say I'm the average busy person in the States...
...who would like to be healthy but doesn't have time to cook at home.
What's for breakfast?
Most people's options are limited to things...
...like a McGriddle with hash browns and coffee,...
...or maybe an egg and processed cheese sandwich...
...with Tater tots at Dunkin' Donuts,...
...or some pancakes at Denny's, if you have more time.
Surely, some people will have healthier options than that...
...but I'm trying to think of what most people are going to have access to.
So, what's a quick breakfast in Japan?
While there's more than 6,000 fast food establishments in Japan,...
...there's also 5,000 rice bowl establishments.
The big ones are Yoshinoya, Sukiya and Matsuya.
And for four dollars at Sukiya, for breakfast,...
...you can get plain rice, miso soup with seaweed, an egg, baked fish,...
...and a small potato salad comes with it.
If I'm extra hungry, maybe I'll add some kimchi, fermented soybeans...
... and stewed beef for four dollars.
Or you can put together a reasonably healthy meal from a convenience store.
At a Japanese convenience store,...
...I can get a rice ball, which is just rice, salmon and salt,...
...a small salad, or a package of sushi, or a thing of fish with miso,...
...or some soup.
I was pretty impressed with how little junk is in this.
It's basically just vegetables, pork and fish broth.
And there's a bunch of foods like this.
Here's what I can get for under ten dollars, USD.